[Música]
hola como estan yo soy míchel gonzález
soy artista de costa rica muchísimas
gracias a las mujeres por invitarme por
darme este espacio para contarles un
poquito de mí y de dónde vengo en el
diego garcía conocido como el tóner o
productor musical y guitarrista de
españa de valencia valencia
bueno y pues vamos a tocar les tenemos
algunas sorpresas para ustedes hoy pero
bueno contándoles un poco sobre mis
inicios yo soy vengo de una familia muy
artística desde que éramos muy pequeños
teníamos la casa justo a la parte del
estudio de grabación de mi papá él es
músico me hacía muchos comerciales
cuando pues llorando muy pequeña no sé
si ustedes se acuerdan de galletas tipo
el comercial que era tengo que lograr
que vuelvas conmigo
o los de derby no sé hay un montón de
caminos que según él en el horizonte
eran buenísimos te los voy a enseñar
después pero bueno él hace muchos
comerciales y desde que yo era muy
pequeña llegaba el estudio comenzando
agencia tortillas para los clientes
llegar a venderles las tortillas pero
luego me fue interesando más por la
parte técnica mi papá me enseñaba poco a
poco obviamente cómo iba funcionando
todo como se microfonía va entonces
digamos que el estudio se convirtió como
una universidad más o menos este y me
enseñó mucho a estar en ese ambiente en
el estudio y ver cómo funcionaba todo
como fluía todo en un estudio de
grabación y pues luego en la noche que a
veces yo me escapaba a mis papás van a
saber esos hasta ahora me iba a dormir y
luego me escapa mío por la puerta al
estudio encendía todo y me quedaba ahí
toda la noche se convertía como un
santuario donde podía improvisar crear
sin que nadie me viera y no habían
ventanas así que el sonido
y sabía qué hora era entonces y me
quedaba por ahora me acuerdo que me
quedaba escuchándome en el micrófono
cambiando de efectos a veces esté
probando cada efecto probando cada
instrumento
bueno entonces quería queríamos
enseñarles más o menos cómo improvisamos
es diferente pues hay muchas maneras de
improvisar obviamente de componer pero
así más o menos es nuestra dinámica y es
como una comunicación como un juego de
ping pong
me da algunos acordes o habéis hecho
empiezo con la voz y nos vamos adaptando
nos vamos comunicando y viendo a veces
sale a veces nos sale pero pues de eso
se trata de ir soltándose
no hemos practicado una vez estamos a
ver qué es lo que nos sale
[Música]
y
t
[Música]
qué más
además también
[Música]
madres nada
télam
[Música]
no
milan
[Música]
para el tata
no no
amiga
pero
no
[Música]
tú
i
[Música]
me encanta
y
lo vamos a desarrollar pero bueno esto
más o menos nuestra dinámica a veces yo
vengo con una melodía ya hecha a veces
no a veces me inspiro usando efectos de
sonido
que de hecho cuando cumplí como contenía
como 1920 por ahí la única manera en que
mis amigas me sacaran a un club oa una
fiesta asia había un dj y yo podía
llevar mi mi casa efectos y silicón se
llama esa marca y mi micrófono y mis
cosas y me iba a subir con el dj
improvisar
de hecho toque mucho con diego lópez es
un dj muy reconocido en costa rica y
asia si no sigamos improvisando
y pues les quería hablar un poco sobre
una condición que tengo que se llama
sinestesia que también me ayuda mucho
a entender la música y el arte de una
manera distinta eso es como una mezcla
de sensaciones
puedo ver colores con acuerdos musicales
con con notas o puedo ver texturas
sentir las texturas hay muchos muchos
tipos de sinestesia
y mucha gente a veces ni sabemos yo me
di cuenta que yo tenía sinestesia hasta
que cumplí como 22 una cosa así que me
expresaba de una manera muy distinta
hacia hacia las personas
y pues una manera en la que me gusta
producir
'no es ampliando todo dando a ver
grabando sonidos distintos me gusta
mucho las texturas entonces por ejemplo
otro día abrí una botella que era tenía
gas y lo grabé luego lo meto en el
lógico pro tools o lo que sea que usen
para comparar este hacer música y uno va
cambiando el sonido lo va transformando
[Música]
y pues bueno eso es una manera que
utilizo que es divertida y graban dos
unidos y luego uno los va convirtiendo
en lo que quiera convertirlo o sino la
otra manera que hago haces es en un
lienzo y empiezo a pintar lo que lo que
escucho entonces por ejemplo diego toca
un acorde
y entonces digamos que aquí yo veo
colores como verde musgo con estos
acordes entonces comienzo es como was
comienzo a hacer el fondo del cuadro y
eso es lo que me va a dar es como la
atmósfera en donde estoy verdad cómo se
siente el ambiente cómo está cómo se
siente el aire pesado o no o más
menos pesado y pues va poniendo como un
poco el muro de la canción entonces voy
haciendo eso y luego la parte ya
melódica
es ir como dibujando que hay sobre qué
está pasando en ese en esa atmósfera
que está pasando en ese espacio entonces
ahí voy yo no sé dibujando formas
geométricas o
dependiendo de cómo de como todo verdad
cómo me sienta que notas que
instrumentos están tocando cada
instrumento tiene una vibración distinta
entonces pues es una es una manera de
invitarlos a que aquí jueguen y es
importante jugar con todo esto porque
pues también me ha pasado que por la
parte técnica me he quedado varada
porque no me gusta porque me da pereza
porque no entiendo y pues he tenido la
oportunidad por dicha de que mi papá me
enseñara desde que era muy pequeña pero
yo sé que muchas personas no han tenido
esa oportunidad entonces no importa a
veces si uno no tiene una computadora o
lo que sea para grabar
lo que es importante es abrir la mente y
ver con qué sonidos puedo jugar puedo
grabar el sonido de la mesa
y luego el sonido del vaso
y lo que sea que haga sonido puedo
juntar esos sonidos y luego empezar a
improvisar con la voz si quiero
pero no importa el final no es ni
siquiera de solo crear una canción es es
simplemente abrir la mente adaptarse y
y abrirse y acoplarse a lo que hay y
utilizarlo asia para la creatividad de
uno
[Música]
bueno hablando de sinestesia este vamos
a tocar otra canción que se llama
midnight son estas de mi segundo ep que
se llama de río para ball y la canción
original tiene sonidos más fríos espumas
industrial y esta versión es más
con su dice wang orgánica orgánica y
nada colores más
como naranjas como más acogedoras
aquí va menos
y
[Música]
o no
cual estoy matando
pauli
[Música]
laurel
así que por qué usan
aquí el maratón
hola
muy creado seis partes
ya que lewis
sí no
[Música]
sí
jueves
[Música]
y
si james lewis
puedo estar
como ese que es mayáhuel de pared
así que por qué están aquí por favor
actor cual
todas las mujeres de espíritu
cuídese
[Música]
será el segundo
más
así esa ayuda
y tú o jueves
o
webó
[Música]
es muy bien
ese fue mi lights
también algo más que quería contarles
también que a mí me pasa mucho pues
desde pequeña he tratado de nunca he
tenido la disciplina para seguir un
instrumento y ser persistente en
practicar para ser como diego
entonces este quiero decirle a todas
esas personas que a veces piensan que
porque no saben tocar un instrumento no
no pueden ir más allá yo creo que como a
mí me pasó
yo no soy guitarrista pero pues toco dos
notas y eso me ayuda a ver cuando ya me
sienta cómodo tocando esas dos notas
empieza a progresar con la voz que es
pues es mi instrumento
primario se diría
entonces no hace falta saber tocar
instrumento es definitivamente uno muy
bueno
es increíble si no puede pero para
aquellos que no lo sepan o no saben
tocar piano y quieren hacer algo no
importa que cumplir lo importante es lo
que visualicen
y plantean la idea
bueno de costa rica
para más
bueno yo me fui de costa rica cuando
tenía como
24 años yo estuve en una banda que se
puede usted desconocen que se llama
trans y pues de la banda me fui a suecia
me quedé un tiempo por europa
y de ahí me logré ir a los ángeles no
quise ir más a costa rica pues me
fascina pero sentía que tenía que crecer
más como personas quería tener más
experiencias y nunca había vivido sola
en otro país me parecía interesante la
experiencia de no tener a nadie conocido
y de solo estar conmigo misma y conocer
partes distintas que no conocía miedos
estando en mi zona de confort digamos
que pues es dificilísimo y es difícil no
tener dinero y es difícil este puedes
pulsar la pero es demasiado importante
es lo que más nos va a ayudar aa
formarnos como personas cuando estamos
solos y tenemos que
este
subsistir tenemos que ser creadores de
nuestro día a día tenemos que improvisar
entonces pues la improvisación en la
música me ayudó mucho en eso también y a
fluir a un día y pues nos conocimos y
pues fui conociendo bastantes artistas
con el tiempo compositores productores
terminé en el leyton en el que estoy el
sueco se llama snow récords
y pues este año ya que una canción que
se llama goofy la compusimos al
principio de año
obviamente no sabíamos cómo iba a ser el
resto del año pero queríamos hacer una
canción que nos diera mucha energía
y nos inspiramos muchos sonidos como de
los 90s el reggae pop eso page judy
forti
la hicimos a principio de año con el
folk al binner la idea
y pues bien yo hicimos una versión un
poco distinta a cabo de hecho sacar wifi
parte 2 con sofía reyes y de la ghetto y
yo son gracias a que me vine aquí a los
angles y salí un poco este lo logré
conocer y pues logramos colaborar en
esta canción pero bueno les vamos a
tocar esta versión nuestro
i
[Música]
amor en el saco
a moreno lugar y
deslaves en tan voy a ir hoy
la mayor pena me 2
oneto y un
one que esa mañana hoy hoy
que fuera del cuerpo agregó más fina
cantante pidió mantener seis en el cielo
o lo más para hoy
[Música]
luces
aunque su consulta contra que haces o te
cortas
wintek la ejecutiva fecha mayo se van a
empujar
[Música]
guyton y novedoso
lo deja un software hoy
hoy
hicimos clave luego más final soldado
tessio no es tuyo entienden igual que
luz
ahora
youtube
buenos aires la copa no se llamará luz
de compulsa cheque lado twitter que el
lobo hay que conocí a mucha más gente y
podemos ver que sus consultas han dado
casos en marcha teclado cueste que lo
escuchamos así o se mueven
[Música]
y quiero muero sube hasta el cielo
lento en un fuego lo veis
[Música]
quiero muero su bebé hasta el cielo
lento en fuego
mi mente
[Música]
a
no
[Música]
está
de más
cuesta que lo hacía mucho más tiempo
o
[Música]
muchas gracias
bueno esto fue el fin muchísimas gracias
este de ex mujeres por haberme invitado
a habernos invitado y gracias diego por
por unirte
y nada
muy agradecida de ojalá esto se puede
hacer en vivo muy pronto los quiero
mucho a todos por unirse no
[Música]